escondidos tras el tronco de un árbol
estos combatientes palestinos responden
al fuego de los soldados israelíes en
las calles de gionin momentos antes
alrededor de las diez de la mañana hora
local varios vehículos militares
israelíes entraron en el campo de
refugiados las fuerzas israelíes dicen
que están llevando a cabo una operación
para detener a sospechosos palestinos
pero el convoy aquí en el fondo de esta
imagen de aficionado es emboscado
la resistencia estaba preparada e
infligió bajas directas a los soldados
israelíes gracias a una emboscada
dirigida por las brigadas casam el
ejército israelito más represalias por
tierra y por aire según un fotógrafo de
la agencia France un helicóptero israelí
disparó dos misiles un hecho
extremadamente raro y el primero desde
la segunda entifada entre 2000 y 2005
decenas de palestinos resultaron heridos
varios murieron como este adolescente de
15 años
en el momento en la incursión del
ejército israelí corrió en su dirección
quería morir como un mártir después de
la muerte de uno de sus amigos en el
enfrentamiento también resultaron
heridos soldados israelíes evacuados en
helicóptero las tensiones entre las dos
partes han ido en aumento desde hace
varios meses y con la llegada al poder
del gobierno más derechista de la
historia de Israel Un gobierno que ASUME
la responsabilidad de la operación
llevada a cabo el lunes
en la lucha contra el terrorismo no hay
compromisos Seguiremos adoptando un
enfoque ofensivo y proactivo
utilizaremos todos nuestros medios y
golpearemos a los terroristas donde
quiera que estén
este domingo el Primer Ministro Benjamín
natanyahu aprobó medidas para facilitar
la construcción de nuevos asentamientos
en cisjordania